If we apply this higher amount of friction, it's going to take 3.4 seconds to bring the car
to a complete stop and for the smaller amount of friction, it's 4.9 seconds,
and now let's look at how to compute this.
We have to take two different forces into account.
The force due to friction, biking that is, and the force due to gravity.
Newton says F=ma.
The force due to friction equals the mass of the car
times the deceleration as we are breaking off the car.
But the force exerted due to friction is amountable of the force exerted by gravity
with the proportionality constant µ and what's force the exerted by gravity?
It's the mass of the car times the gravitational acceleration of the earth.
You see that's Newton law applied in the reverse direction.
If you look closely, you'll see that mass cancels from both sides of the equation
and the deceleration equals the constant of friction times the gravitation acceleration.
This is one funny consequence for astronauts.
When you try to break a car on the moon, the gravitational acceleration is far less than on earth
and so the deceleration is far less than on earth.
Breaking is far more ineffective on the moon than on earth.
Now we can use this result to look at how speed depends on time.
The deceleration is constant so the velocity decreases
by a certain fixed amount of meters per second.
The relationship between velocity and time is linear
and the slope of this line is given by the acceleration.
This side has a length of 1, this side has a length of a, the acceleration,
which is, as we now know, the constant of friction times the gravitational acceleration.
You'll see two similar triangles in here.
We have the time it takes to come to a complete stop divided by the initial velocity
equals 1 divided by the deceleration.
The time it takes to come to a complete stop equals 120 km/h divided by our deceleration
which is the constant of friction times the gravitational acceleration.
We have to go from kilometers per hour to meters per second.
The gravitation acceleration equals 9.81 m/s² .
To make this work, we should be using m/s for the velocity as well.
One kilometer is 1000 meters and 1 hour amounts to 3,600 seconds.
Now you can do the math.